sale ambiance et nous aurons une
entreprise ambulance
nous passons la plupart du temps en fin
de la journée et la nuit
[Musique]
lorsque nous avons un transport sur
paris où une consultation doit temps de
quelques temps ben on vient faire un
petit torrent bologne et on connaît à
l'endroit où on peut se retrouver après
dans une certaine activité ont versé des
imprévus un revenu d'un long parcours
bon si vite et ils ont plus rayonnante
et d'habitude j'ai envie il y avait un
petit a boudé par le fait de transporter
des personnes ça si bien et tout mais
malgré tout avec l'envi c'est vite parti
on a fait l'amour pour en conduisant bas
il ya les mathis balle un peu bon qu'il
ya son regard aussi qui veut dire où il
mais c'est pas un peu étrange quand même
non non non non de cette façon là non et
en plus c'est bien suspendu